What are they doing in a bit?
Do something artistic, everyone.
Jump, I don't know.
We have to record you sometimes.
Yeah, me doing nothing.
Me.
Like, we never take pictures of you.
Oh, that's OK.
When you come back to Australia.
I never really feel...
It'll be a while, I think, unfortunately.
Do you think next year?
Maybe, yeah.
I think at this point, maybe, like,
I'd probably be allowed to get back off the field
at the end of the year,
but we'd still want to be careful.
It just depends on getting yourself stronger.
But if you keep training, like, you'll come back way stronger.
Supposedly.
It's hard because, like, I felt like I was in really good shape before,
so it feels like what I would have to do to, like,
come back stronger would be, like, insane.
You'll get there.
Yeah, I don't feel like I'm in a huge rush at the moment.